wir haben schon heute viele vorträge
über den begriff des bösen aus der
geschichte der philosophie gehört und
heute möchte ich eine zeitgenössische
debatte skizzieren über wie und ob man
das böse konzipieren kann
zu diesem zweck werde ich zwei methoden
die moralisches böse thematisieren
beschreiben und bewerten
eine ist katholisch und die andere
recken steinig der platonische ansatz
bringt die position vor an dass die
notwendigen und hinreichenden
bedienungen alle begriffe bestimmt
werden können
der beginn steirische ansatz besteht
darauf dass viele begriffe unter solchem
platonischen hat sagt heitz ideal nicht
hinreichend erfasst werden können
begriffe können unscharfe verschob
verschwommenen grenzen haben darauf
aufbauen müssen viele begriffe durch
paradigmatische anwendungsfälle und
familien ähnlichkeiten verstanden werden
beide ansätze haben deutliche vorteile
und besondere nachteile die sich direkt
auf unser verständnis böse handlung
auswirken
der patron ische ansatz erfordert die
notwendigen und herrchen hinreichenden
bedienungen des konzepts des bösen
diese technische ansatz hat zwei
vorteile 1 durch die bestimmung der
definition des bösen bietet er ein
volles verständnis des bösen an
2 er ermöglicht die identifizierung des
bösen durch seine bedingungen in dieser
ansatz war schon recht erfolgreich
wir haben derzeit mehrere überzeugende
definition der definitionen des bösen in
der philosophischen literatur die
existenz mehrerer überzeugende thesen
bedeutet jedoch jedoch auch dass es
unklar bleibt welche theorie richtig ist
eine position des konzeptuellen
journalismus für das konzept des bösen
ist ein möglicher ausgang dieser
vielzahl posible theorien
der nachteil dieser position ist das
konzeptuelle terrorismus möglicherweise
so konzeptuelle unbestimmtheit führt der
weg ins steirische ansatz zum bösen
verführt das ziel die notwendigen und
hinreichenden bedingungen zu bestimmen
stattdessen fordert er dass
paradigmatische fälle des börsen zuerst
identifiziert werden und dann es so
bewertet werden ob andere fälle den
paradigmatischen fällen ausreichend
erinnern
damit sie auch aus böse identifiziert
werden können
der vorteil dieses ansatz ist dass wir
uns nicht auf die notwendige und
hinreichende bedienungen des bösen
konzentrieren müssen sondern die
signifikanz des bösen in unserem leben
in fokus nehmen die tatsache dass das
böse ein fester bestandteil des
menschlichen verhaltens ist hat
entscheidende auswirkungen darauf wie
wir über uns selbst und unsere
interaktion mit anderen denken sollte
der wittgenstein ische ansatz bietet
einen entscheidenden einblick in die
menschliche agentur und in unsere
moralische beziehungen an
der nachteil dieses ansatz ist dass wir
ohne einen so dass wir ohne eine
vorherige und genaue definition des
bösen es erst dann erkennen können
nachdem es aufgetreten ist und wenn wir
darauf warten etwas böses nur dann zu
nennen nachdem es sich enthüllt hat das
heißt wenn wir es nur durch seine
entsetzlichen konsequenzen
identifizieren können
dann sind wir nicht mehr in der lage
seine schädlichen auswirkungen zu
lindern oder sein auftreten zu
verringern
wir kommen zu spät an den ort des bösen
und können nichts anderes tun aus sein
häufiges erscheinen trauern
ich nenne den ersten ansatz photonisch
ganz einfach war seine methodik auf
daten zurückgeht
sokrates engagierte seine
gesprächspartner um
schwer fassbare begriffe wie
förmlichkeit gerechtigkeit oder wissen
klar zu definieren
laub partner passt alles auf der welt in
eine kategorie oder krass oder feld und
kategorien können klar definiert werden
wenn wir die notwendigen und
hinreichenden bedingungen für konzepte
finden wissen wir genau was sie bedeuten
diese methodik ist in der gesamten
geschichte der philosophie
besonders in der analytischen
philosophie zentral geblieben
die bestimmung der notwendigen und
hinreichenden bedienungen eines begriffs
verdeutlicht welche bedingungen zu einer
bestimmten instanz des begriffs führen
wir erfahren welche bedingungen erfüllt
sein müssen notwendig und welche
bedingungen garantieren hinreichend das
vorkommen eines bestimmten fonds oder
eine bestimmte instanz oder situation
ein präzises und war das verständnis von
konzepten ist nicht nur an sich wertvoll
oft kann dieses verständnis auch
praktische konsequenzen haben
durch das verständnis des kerns eines
konzepts wissen wir welche bedingungen
zu einem bestimmten fall des konzepts
anlass geben und dadurch können wir
einen solchen fall richtig erkennen dann
ist auftritt so denken sie an sokratis
diskussionen mit guter von oder oder
memo das verständnis der essenz des
bösen kann das wissen über die
bedingungen die sein auftreten
ermöglichen erzeugen
dieses verständnis ist unabdingbar für
eine bestimmte praktische konsequenz die
wenn es um böses handeln geht von
entscheidender bedeutung ist wenn wir
daran interessiert sind die fälle von
bösen handeln in der zukunft zu
verringern
dann brauchen wir ein klares verständnis
der bedingungen die das auftreten des
bösen garantieren
mit diesem wissen können wir böses
handlungen erkennen bevor es sich zeigt
und ich halte dies für den stärksten
vorteil des platonischen ansatzes
was sind die plausibelste theorien über
die notwendigen und
hinreichenden bedingungen des bösen es
gibt zwei hauptkategorien
beide setzten sich das ziel das böse von
welchem oder alltäglichen fehlverhalten
zu unterscheiden um das böse zu
definieren
ich nenne die erste kategorie täter
accounts und die zweite notierte
schadens accounts aus gründen die stadt
werden perfekte der täter account suchen
die definierenden charakteristik des
bösen in der psychologischen verfassung
des täters titel accounts sind
charakteristisch ökologisch dichte
theorien was bedeutet da sie ein
komplexes ökologisches merkmal
bösartigen handels identifizieren
diese theorien stellen da dass das böse
durch eine oder mehrere bestimmte
eigenschaften eines täters behandlungen
definiert wird
es gibt mehrere prima fazit plausibles
ökologische merkmale die eine weltliche
handlung zu einer bösen handlung machen
könnte
ein vorschlag ist dass das böse durch
sadistische absichten oder und
motivationen hervorgerufen wird
argumentiert dass ein böse art
durchgeführt wird wenn der täter sich am
schmerz der opfer erfreut verlost einmal
behauptet in ähnlicher weise das böse
handlungen forscher handlungen sind die
iren täten gefallen
alternativ behauptet dass das böse gegen
die moral verstoßen oder ist fällt
verhalten das getan wird weil es falsch
ist
andere philosophen finden dass das böse
nicht durch ihre anwesenheit sondern
durch das fehlen gewisse gewisse
motivationen oder psychologische
merkmale charakterisiert ist
februar behauptet dass böses handlung
von jemandem ausgeführt wird der auf das
vorhandensein bedeutsame gründe gegen
ihr handeln verstummt oder verzichtet
morgen definiert das böse auf folgende
weise
diese definition basiert auch die
beobachtung dass die meisten von uns
psychologische barrieren gegen die
berücksichtigung bestimmter
handlungsoptionen haben die schaden an
anderen oder das leiden andere
veranlassen
dann so wenn solche psychologischen
barriere überwunden oder erodiert werden
wird das böse auf der vorteil diese
psychologisch dichten ansätze ist da sie
eindeutig ein bestimmtes merkmal
identifizieren dass das böse von einem
blossen helfer hatten unterscheidet und
die notwendigen und hinreichenden
bedingungen des bösen bereitstellt wenn
eine handlung aufgrund von sadismus
missachtung der moral psychologischem
verstummen moralische gründe der
abwesenheit moralische barrieren oder
einen anderen spezifischen
psychologischen komponente auftritt dann
ist die handlung böse
diese philosophischen theorien scheinen
den schrecklichsten bösen taten und böse
tätern zu beschreiben
trotz ihrer scheinbaren plausibilität
werden täter account des bösen von
konzeptionellen nachteilen bedrängt der
erste nachteil der psychologe sticht
integrieren das böse ist da sie zu
anspruchsvoll sind
es ist womöglich dass einige täter das
böse die genannten beweggründe bereit
haben diese charakteristika sind aber zu
begrenzt um alle böse tat
zu erklären empirische beweise stützen
die schlussfolgerung dass gewöhnliche
individuen böse handlungen aus
alltäglichen motivationen durchführen
wie zb gehorsamkeit gegenüber autorität
angst oder gruppenzwang und wir haben
gerade von über 1 terry gehört zweitens
sind accounts philosophische mangelhaft
war sie behaupten dass jede
durchgeführte handlung unter der aus
böse ermittelten motivation selbst böse
sein muss zum beispiel bedeutet dies für
steiner und medien dass jede sadistisch
motivierte handlungen böse ist
infolgedessen qualifizierten sich aber
aus böse selbst handlungen die harmlos
sind oder menschen gar nicht schädigen
solange sie die relevanten beweggründe
besitzen aber die bloße anwesenheit
eines britischen psychologischen
merkmals selbst eines gänzlich
verächtlichen verwandelt nicht
notwendigerweise eine alltäglichkeit hat
in eine böse tat konnte fand was wir
schon gehört haben
die nächste kategorie von definitionen
die die ich nun zierte schadens accounts
nennen betrachten sowohl die opfer als
auch die täter aus wesentliche
bestandteile böse handlungen in der
philosophische literatur gibt es mehrere
der philosophisch attraktive versionen
distanzieren montierten schadens
accounts extreme beschreibt die
wesentliche art von schaden aus live
hacking wobei live hacking holmes
interview behauptet dass das böse ist
signifikante schaden und ein und
unentschuldbare absicht ein unwürdiges
c/o zu bewirken zuzulassen oder zu
bezeugen
diese theorien vermeiden die einwände
gegen täter accounts erstens indem sie
der böse handlung eine bestimmte art von
schaden identifizieren nämlich
unerträglichen extremen signifikanten
oder lebens zerstörenden schäden
schließen schließen schließen die
handlungen aus bei denen nur eine
geringe menge an schaden auftritt
zweitens bleiben nun zierte schadens
accounts offen für die möglichkeit einer
vielzahl von motivationen für böses
handeln mit psychologisch dünnen
modellen vertreten sie die restriktiven
psychologisch dichten andeutungen der
täter accounts die das böse auf eine
bestimmte motivation beschränken und
psychologisch schöne modelle
identifizieren keine bestimmte
moderation oder absicht aus notwendig
trotz diese kommerziell konzeptionellen
vorteile haben nur und zierte schaden
sekunden drei nachteile erstens ist es
nicht ganz klar was schaden unerträglich
extrem signifikant oder lebens
zerstörung macht zweitens könnte man
behaupten dass unerträglich signifikant
extrem leben zerstören keine objektiven
kriterien haben
drittens könnte man auch einwenden
obwohl diese definitionen sich ändern
sind sie auch unterschiedlich
deshalb bleibt die definition des bösen
unklar
lukas betrachtet diese vielheit
plausible theorien aus einem grund einer
position des konzeptuellen terrorismus
für das böse handeln einzugehen da
mehrere philosophische konzepte des
bösen kohärent und wertvoll sind gibt es
keine guten gründe dafür die
konzeptionelle priorität eine einzige
theorie zu beanspruchen meint er
ich stimme zu dass die annahme einer
position des konzeptuellen parole
aufgrund seiner konzeptuellen offenheit
attraktiv sein kann
ich befürchte aber dass konzeptuelle
breite leicht zu konzeptuelle unklarheit
führen kann
aus antwort auf diese sorge könnte man
argumentieren dass wir die vielzahl der
plausiblen definitionen aus hinweis
darauf interpretieren sollten dass es
keine einzige definition des bösen gibt
die alle möglichen fälle von von bösem
handlungen abdeckt vielleicht ist der
grund dafür dass die art und weise in
der menschen böses tun so vielfältig und
kreativ ist das eine einzige definition
seine eigenschaften nicht genau
beschreiben kann
denn diese behauptung war wäre wäre es
sinnvoll die suche nach dem wesentlichen
eigenschaft und das böse vielleicht
aufzugeben
aber die suche nach der essenz des bösen
aufzugeben bedeutet nicht gleich auf
eine philosophische analyse des bösen zu
verzichten
verzichten wir schon bekannt ist
stricken stand fest dass dinge oder
begriffe die oft aus wesentlich
miteinander verbundene angesehen werden
tatsächlich durch viele einander
überlappende familienähnliche
ähnlichkeiten verbunden verbunden sein
können
die aber keine allgemeine gemeinsamkeit
aufweisen
anstatt nach einer einzigen essenz eines
begriffs zu suchen sollten wir nach
zitat ähnlichkeiten beziehungen und eine
ganze reihe neuer davon ende zitat
suchen was wir von wittgensteins ansicht
entnehmen können ist sobald wir uns
nicht mehr damit beschäftigen ein
einzelnes wesen des bösen zu
identifizieren
dass es sowieso vielleicht gar nicht
gibt oder nicht mehr darüber streiten
welche konkurrierende definition die
richtige ist wenn jeder auf eine gewisse
wahrheit hinweis
und nachdem wir die familienähnlichkeit
des börsen bestimmt haben können wir
unsere untersuchung der frage der
signifikanz des bösen für menschen
zuwenden
dh die abkehr von der suche nach der
essenz des bösen zu gunsten seiner
familien ähnlichkeiten führt uns nicht
nur näher zu einem korrekten verständnis
des bösen an
so wird es eine aufmerksamkeits wendung
auf einen aspekt der börsen aktion der
wichtige ist auf seine notwendige und
hinreichende bedingungen und das ist
seine auswirkungen auf unser leben
die kommenden prominenteste
zeitgenössische verteidiger dieser
ansicht ist niemand sie schreibt von
intrinsity zu nehmen die frage gestellt
passt das böse mit uns macht wird sie
nicht ihre diskussionen auf die
unmittelbare opfer des bösen begrenzen
sie meint wirklich uns das heißt wir
alle die in der welt leben und
beobachten oder menschliche geschichte
erleben die uns manchmal wie eine
undurchdringliche monotonie der
grausamkeiten erscheint von der
psychologe james rolle wenn wir uns auf
die signifikanz des bösen konzentrieren
werden zwei fakten über die
menschlichkeit und unsere welt offenbart
die unsere gedanken informieren oder
drastisch verändern
zuerst wird es erkannt dass das böse
eine durchdringende und tief verwurzelte
eigenschaft des menschlichen verhaltens
der holocaust die killing fields in
kambodscha die vergewaltigungs lagen in
bosnien
die zahl der unumstrittenen beispiele
des bösen ist riesig und diese nur drei
beispiele aus den letzten 75 jahren
es gibt leider keinen mangel an bösen
ereignissen auf die wir zurückgreifen
können um nach gemeinsamkeiten und
ähnlichkeiten zu suchen
das böse ist kein irrweg und auch nicht
vergänglich
vielmehr ist es ist es ein dauerhafter
zustand der menschliche interaktion aus
dem häufigen vorkommende der
börsenhändler ergibt sich eindeutig dass
die welt nicht ist wie sie sein sollte
die fakten zeigen nach niemand dass
unschuldige menschen oft und enorme art
und weise leiden werden moralisch
verachtenswerte menschen gedeihen wenn
das böse in der tat verschanzt und
gegenwärtig in menschliche interaktion
ist dann kann man nicht mehr nahe
glauben dass die welt ist wie sie sein
soll
und niemand glaubt es gibt eine große
kluft zwischen sein und sohlen und sie
ist unüberwindbar
zweitens wird es erkannt dass das damit
das böse ein sehr verbreitetes und
permanentes merkmal der menschlichen
interaktion sein kann muss es den
einfachen menschen möglich sein taten
des bösen zu begehen
natürlich sind die meisten menschen
keine genozid etr oder fanatischen fotos
aber diejenigen die böse taten aus
führend sind keine teuflischen oder
monströsen personen gewöhnliche menschen
begehen außergewöhnliche böse handlungen
diese situation ist ansicht ist wertvoll
denn wir sind denn wir sind gezwungen
börse ohne psychopath ihr zu
konfrontieren banale böse täter wie zb
arendt eichmann erschrecken uns aufgrund
ihrer normalität durch die annahme der
banalität des bösen müssen wir die
möglichkeit konfrontiert und dass jede
gewöhnliche person
wir selbst einen akt des bösen begehen
könnte diese tatsachen über das böse
spiegeln deutlich eine immense kluft
zwischen sein und sollen das böse sollte
nicht so weit verbreitet sein doch ist
es so gewöhnliche menschen sollten nicht
anfällig für handlungen der
schrecklichen brutalität sein aber wir
sind so und niemand beobachten zu
wiederholen diese tatsachen können uns
dazu bringen vertrauen in die welt zu
verlieren und fordern unser bedürfnis
heraus uns darin zu orientieren
dieser verlust und diese herausforderung
haben jedoch einen normativen wert das
heißt nicht dass das gewonnene wissen
über uns selbst oder über die welt böse
handlungen rechtfertigt der preis ist
einfach zu hoch
jedoch kann die anerkennung der fakten
bezüglich der moralischen interaktion
eine entscheidende rolle bei der
entwicklung eine fähigkeit auf andere
menschen angemessen zu reagieren spielen
es wird zb zunächst der gerechte welt
glaube und seine folgen skizziert der
gerechte welt glaube ist die vorstellung
dass in der welt oder universum gute
taten belohnt und böse taten bestraft
werden der glaube stützt sich auf eine
kosmischen moralischen gerechtigkeit die
den menschlichen handlungen und ihre
konsequenzen zu grunde liegt diese
glaube wird sich in üblichen ausdrücken
wie man erntet was man säht geäußert
trotz der allgegenwärtigkeit solche
ausdrücke sind sie einfach falsch das
leid das böse aktion kritisiert es
unverdient und unzumutbar die prävalenz
des bösen erklärt sich durch seiner
begehung von gewöhnlichen menschen die
eine kosmischen wohlverdienten strafen
nie unterliegen für unsere zwecke heute
ist es einfach relevant dass zahlreiche
psychologische studien gezeigt haben
dass die aufrechterhaltung des gerechten
welt glaubens
negative konsequenzen hat opfer werden
für ihr eigenes leiden beschuldigt und
ungerechte politik wird unterstützt das
heißt dann mit falschen vorstellungen
des bösen werden vorkommen des bösen
erhöht oder verschlechtert wenn die
ablehnung von wahrheiten über das böse
negative folgen für moralische
interaktion haben kann dann könnte
wiederum die akzeptanz die akzeptanz
diese wahrheiten positive auswirkungen
haben indem wir akzeptieren dass das
böse sowohl ein tief verwurzeltes
merkmalen menschliche interaktion ist
auch das gewöhnliche menschen täten das
börsen sind müssen wir auch glauben
müssen wir auch glauben wie zb den
gerechten welt glauben aufgeben
mit der erkennung der signifikanz des
bösen nämlich dass das böse immer
ungerecht ungerechtfertigt und
allgegenwärtig ist und nie von einer
kosmischen gerechtigkeit bestraft wird
kommen wir zu zwei kritischen
schlussfolgerungen opfer der das börsen
verdienen ihr leiden nicht und wir
müssen alles dafür tun um situative
belastungen und biologische
dispositionen die zu böse handlung
führen zu erkennen damit wir
möglicherweise das auftreten des bösen
minimieren können
ein fokus auf die signifikanz des bösen
könnte diese nützlichen praktischen
konsequenzen haben
wenn diese wenn diese positiven folgen
eine bessere chance haben sich mit der
signifikanz des börsen- und nicht mit
seinen notwendigen und hinreichenden
hinreichenden bedingungen und umgesetzt
zu werden
dann sollten wir vielleicht zu dem
schluss kommen dass die suche nach der
definition des bösen entweder weniger
wichtig ist ist aus die analyse seines
signifikanz oder bei kinder sogar die
anerkennung seiner signifikanz laut
nehmen
wenn ja dann sollten wir auch die suche
nach den notwendigen und hinreichenden
bedienungen des bösen verzichten
stattdessen sollten wir unsere gesamten
wissenschaftlichen ressourcen nutzen um
die signifikanz des bösen in unserem
leben zu verstehen
trotz des eindeutigen normativen wer
diese position hat sie einen
potenziellen fehler indem wir die suche
auch das wesen wesen des bösen
veranlasst verlassen und konzentrieren
und nur auf seine familie ähnlichkeiten
geben wir auch zu dass wir das böse nur
dann identifizieren können wenn wir
ersehen
auf diese weise kommen wir immer zu spät
an den ort des bösen erst nachdem die
schrecklichen folgen bereits aufgetreten
sind
wenn die katholischen und big in
spanischen ansätze entscheidende
vorteile und nachteile haben wie sollten
wir eine verdeutlichung des bösen
darlegen
wenn wir es schaffen würden eine
definition des bösen zu formulieren dann
können wir vielleicht die quelle und die
möglichkeit des bösen erkennen
damit wird zumindest das potenzial für
seine prävention eröffnet auch wenn wir
nicht darauf hoffen können dass es
vollständig vom menschlichen verhalten
entfernt entfernt werden kann
hauptsächlich aus diesem grund denke ich
dass wir nicht aufgeben können das böse
genau zu definieren
anderseits ist es klar dass wir auch
unsere wissenschaftlichen ressourcen
dafür einsetzen sollten die signifikanz
des bösen für unser leben zu verstehen
das böse ist ein festes merkmal
menschliche interaktion die anerkennung
dieser eigenschaft beeinflusst unsere
selbstreflektion und wie wir anderen
moralischen agenten begegnen
vielleicht können wir elemente jedes
ansatzes einfach kombinieren
wir bemühen uns darum das böse zu
definieren werden wir gleichzeitig
bedenken dass das streben nach dieser
definition nicht wichtige ist aus die
anerkennung seine signifikanz mit dieser
methode sehe ich keinen
interessenkonflikt eine solche
umfassende ansatz würde die vorteile
beide einsätze potenzieller voranbringen
voranbringen werden sie ihre nachteile
hinterlässt zugegebenermaßen dass dieser
vorschlag ist nicht nicht unglaublich
komplex jedoch es ist auch nicht trivial
so ein umfassender ansatz in bezug auf
das böse ist noch nicht in der
zeitgenössischen philosophische
literatur erschienen was bedeutet dass
seine umsetzung eine willkommene
ergänzung werde die detaillierte
ausführung dieses ansatzes müssen wir
auf eine andere zeit verschieben aber
jetzt sind wir sind wir uns klar darüber
wie wir vorgehen können
dankeschön